devriez-vous payer pour un calibrage
télé des détaillants offrent de calibrer
l'image de votre nouvelle télé pour
ajuster contraste luminosité netteté
couleurs et faire ressortir le meilleur
de votre téléviseur mais ça coûte cher
entre 150 et 300 dollars dans le temps
bobino calibrer les écrans améliorer les
couleurs et atténuer la déformation
d'image mais aujourd'hui vraiment pascal
forget et chroniqueur techno et selon
lui si vous êtes un fanatique de l'image
avec de l'équipement haut de gamme ça
peut en valoir la peine puisque certains
ajustements sont impossibles à réaliser
à l'oeil nu mais pour la plupart des
gens les modes préprogrammés ils font
très bien la faire d'autant plus qu'on
peut les personnaliser vous n'avez pas
touché le bouton laptop
et oui le bouton en général c'est bien
suffisant pour regarder vos émissions
préférées passés le mot
[Musique]